that's where we're taking you the heart
attacks the Lone Star State my name is
Willie Walker jr. I made the greatest
country album of all time these are my
favorite YouTube videos bridge that
we're gonna start with a something hit
me hard this year the death of Prince
and this is a woman who took even worse
than me this is called Prince dick I
don't know what it's called Prince dead
Prince her husband or friend or whatever
it was told her Prince died her first
reaction was Prince Charming but the
second she finds out that it's Prince
she just lost him I mean I was upset but
I didn't do this
and she just starts singing Purple Rain
[Music]
it's not the best version of herb it's
not bad well how bad you think she's
gonna be hating life when she finds out
prince charming alive someone told me
this video was fake but if it's fake I
don't give a it's it's really good I
heard a rumor she's still laying there
she's singing $19.99 right now all right
so the next video is from one of my
favorite comedians ever deep Harvey from
Family Feud name something that follows
the word pork I think somebody said loin
and pork chops or something and this guy
gives the best answer I've ever heard in
my life name something that fuckles the
word pork you PI coupon coupon he says
but Steve Harvey man he takes it like a
chance I mean who's got a better like
look to camera and Steve Harvey hello
Steve Harvey Steve Harvey ever want to
make a country record you know to call
that's some funny stuff man don't be
number what are you - I hate remixes and
then some of some of this a few years
ago with the Slap Chop
[Music]
and I wash this and like I want to watch
it's got kitchen watching on my phones I
can let's do in the car can I check my
phone it's my most listened to song for
like a year
catching man the guy do something crazy
this guy he bit oh yeah of course he bit
a prostitute my man you know you want
your your singers to you know have lived
life anyway hands-down the best song
ever about alright this one's called
drummer at wrong gig this next one no
Texas Motor Speedway I love this video
because there's no explanation on what
the hell this thing is what it what
where are they they're covering ZZ Top
and this drummer is losing his mind it's
pretty badass I know a little bit about
music that's not the easiest way to play
drums I saw ZZ Top live and that their
drummer did not do this
well that's my favorite drummer him and
John Bono my two favorites this is a
classic you guys probably know it it's
the best cry ever and it is the best cry
ever first dude was embarrassing it's
like the guy who hits a game-winning
shot then someone else hits you know
half-court shot to beat him you don't
remember the first guy I love you
there's that little lead-up to it where
he's getting ready
[Music]
they're civilian you doesn't get better
than that man poetry I mean I've seen
Godfather one two and three they got
that new Coppola version where he had it
all in order this video makes this
Godfather look stupid
this last video I don't want to say I
love the song it's not what I would call
a great song but it gets under your skin
it's called queen of Aegina you could
say more by saying less I guess she just
says queen of vagina like 8 million
times kind of mesmerizing my favorite
line that she sings is two plus two
equals vagina we don't it looks like a
take to try to get a record deal
I mean I'd sign her I'm probably the
only one who would anyway check it out
it's a really good song I'm a cover for
my next record if I can get the rights
to it anyway that's my favorite YouTube
videos for Team Coco buy my record it's
better than all the other records they
all suck mine's really good
[Music]
[Applause]